PRESENTER: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for coming to
Authors@Google Presents Brad
Stone, the author of "Amazon
and the Everything Store:
Jeff Bezos and the
Age of Amazon."
It's great to see all you
here this Friday afternoon.
I want to start by
introducing Brad.
Brad has been
covering technology
in Silicon Valley
for over 14 years,
for publications such
as "Newsweek," "New York
Times," and "Bloomberg
Businessweek."
Since you hit it off
the ground, Brad,
I was just wondering how did
you come up with this idea?
How did the project get started?
What was really the
spark of creativity
that led you to write this book?
BRAD STONE: Sure.
Well, I'll start with a
little bit of my history
covering technology.
So I moved out here to the Bay
Area in the late '90s, 1998,
to cover-- I would say I
was working for "Newsweek,"
but I'll say I was working for
the magazine formerly known
as "Newsweek," since
it really doesn't exist
in that incarnation anymore.
And I moved out here to cover
what was really, to New York
media, like a foreign country.
I was the correspondent
to Silicon Valley.
And I was covering their
very early days of Google,
and Apple's
resurgence, and Yahoo,
and all the start-up energy
during the dot-com boom.
And occasionally I
would go up to Seattle
to-- actually the big
story then was Microsoft.
But I remember my
first trip to Amazon.
It was-- I think it
was actually in 2001.
I had covered the company before
then, but I visited in 2001.
And they were in this old
hospital up on a hilltop south
of downtown Seattle.
And the Nisqually earthquake
had just happened.
And you couldn't actually
walk into the front door.
You had to go snake around
through a small door
in the back.
And there was a big sign
warning of falling bricks.
And there were people
with hard hats all around.
And it was a perfect metaphor
for the company at the time.
Because they had ascended to
great heights in the '90s.
And Jeff Bezos was
"Time" Man of the Year.
And the stock price
was through the roof.
And they were expanding
in all directions.
And then it all pretty
much came crumbling down
in the span of two years.
It was a single-digit stock.
Bezos was kind of a pinata.
And I was there to talk to him.
And at the time he
was very voluble.
He actually spent
the first two years
trying to create
the Amazon brand,
and then spent about two
years trying to rescue it,
talking to everybody about
why it was a real company.
And that was sort of my first
experience in a room with Jeff.
And over the next 12 years, I
followed the company closely
for "Newsweek," then
"The New York Times,"
and now "Bloomberg
Business Week."
And the inspiration
for the book--
to get back around
to your question--
was actually in some ways
inspired by you guys here.
Because I have a close friend
and colleague, Steven Levy,
who I worked with
at "Newsweek," who
wrote a great book about
Google called "In the Plex."
And I read that book.
And Steven's kind
of a mentor to me.
And around the same time
that that book came out,
there was "Steve Jobs," by
Walter Isaacson, and of course
there had been some
Facebook books.
And I thought, here are all the
companies changing our world.
And these are all great
books with insider access.
And the great Amazon book
has never been written.
And that is no coincidence.
I mean, I would argue that
Google endeavours to be better
understood by the outside world.
And that's why you guys have
given several journalists
access-- at least some measure
of access-- to the company
to tell its story.
Whereas-- I don't
want to say Amazon
wants to be
misunderstood-- but I
think they're comfortable
with the lack of attention.
And we could talk
about why that is.
So I knew enough at the time,
when I decided to do this,
that I wasn't going
to ask for permission.
I was going to beg for
forgiveness afterwards.
And because In the Plex, and
because Steve Jobs had gotten
so much attention, and also
because the world in New York
publishers-- everyone
was going to bed
and waking up
thinking about Amazon.
It's top of mind right
now, because Amazon's
their biggest distributor and
also their biggest challenger,
because Amazon's self-publishing
now-- publishing authors.
I got some interest in the book.
And then I went to talk to Jeff,
and tell them I was doing it.
And as a result, I got a pretty
good measure of cooperation.
He allowed me to talk to
family members, and friends,
and Amazon senior executives,
while remaining pretty arm's
length, himself.
Because,
extraordinarily, he said
it was too early to tell
the Amazon story, which,
when you think about how much
they've accomplished over two
decades, is I think insightful
as to his ambitions.
But I drew on my
many conversations
with him over the years.
And the result is the book.
PRESENTER: I wanted to
start with this idea
that I've been thinking
a lot about recently,
after having read the book.
And it's the title, "It's
the Everything Store."
And I think here at Google,
we're a search company
first-- not only
a search company,
but that's our bread and butter.
And do you believe
that there would ever
be a point where,
if there truly were
a single store, virtual or
otherwise, that sold everything
on Earth, would it become
too much for consumers?
Would there kind of be a trend
in the opposite direction?
Would it just--
BRAD STONE: Well, right.
I think, in some ways,
we're seeing that.
Amazon is hugely
dominant in e-commerce.
And yet there's no lack
of e-commerce innovation.
There's lots of startups
that have finally figured out
that there's plenty of
invention that you can do,
if you're outside of
Amazon's backyard.
But it's interesting.
Why has it become
the everything store?
Why is it not just a
retailer, but why do they
sell digital products,
and hardware,
and now enterprise services
with the Cloud business?
And that's Jeff.
He's just so relentless in
driving into new markets
and finding new
opportunities for Amazon,
in part, because they had to.
They were early.
He left Wall Street to start
Amazon in 1994 with this idea
that you could start an
"everything" store with books,
because they were very
portable and shippable.
And there were two
major distributors,
so you could find them easily.
And it worked, but it
wasn't a great business.
And when he started expanding
it wasn't a great business.
And even though they
raised a lot of money,
they were really never all that
profitable in the early years.
So he's always been
on a sort of march.
I mean, you guys,
search, right away--
well, OK, not right away, but
by conjoining the advertising
business was a great
high-margin, profitable
business.
And Amazon sort all along
has been on a mission
to kind of invent their way
out of their original business
model.
PRESENTER: Going along with
that, with what you were saying
with some of the challenges, and
just the running the business--
you talk a lot throughout
the book about chaos
and Amazon's
relationship to chaos.
And just how, especially
early in the day,
they were just really
growing so fast that it
was difficult for them to
keep everything in order.
And, I believe it was in either
'99 or 2000, Jeff turned things
around, and said, we're going
to stop growing big fast.
And we're going to
get things in order.
And he said the company
would be profitable by 2001.
What's been your perspective,
having watched the company
from the beginning, and seeing
all of these different goals,
and this relationship that
Amazon has with profitability,
that the stock market
loves monitoring?
BRAD STONE: Right, right.
And in fact, yesterday they
announced their earnings.
And they lost money, and the
stock is-- I think it's up 10%
today.
So it's sort of the
perennial Amazon paradox.
But there are different
contradictions throughout time.
So at the beginning,
a lot of companies
were allowed free capital
and plenty of runway
to go build their businesses
in this great land grab.
And then, the point
you're referencing,
he had to change gears, to
his-- probably-- horror in 2001,
when the stock market crashed.
And they demanded profitability.
And they laid people off.
And they stopped adding
new product assortment
for a few years.
And they had to close the
whole fulfillment center,
and it was a disaster.
And I tell that story,
and it's remarkable.
Because the Amazon
today-- we all
forget that they went through
a period of having to shrink
and actually lay people off.
What's happening now, in terms
of its lack of profitability,
is much different.
So in about 2008,
2009, the Amazon model
starts to really work.
In fact, this whole time eBay
has been valued more highly
than Amazon. eBay was supposedly
the perfect store, and none
of the gritty details
of distribution.
But Amazon's model,
particularly Prime,
the loyalty that
inspired with customers,
and all the work they had done
to figure out their fulfillment
centers-- the mechanics of
just getting all these products
from point A, in the warehouses,
to point B, to people's doors.
And they figured out
they've mastered chaos.
And they actually show
pretty good profits
for a couple of years.
And that's when all the
institutional shareholders come
in and the stock price goes
way up at the same time,
as a matter of fact, that
eBay is kind of engulfed
by its chaos.
It has never figured out
the complexity of shipping.
And the experience on
eBay, at the same time,
is getting worse, while
Amazon's is getting better.
And, in fact, not to really
get off the topic, but eBay
was, at that time, looking
for growth elsewhere.
It went and bought Skype and
Paypal, which worked out,
and lots of Craigslist-type
classified ads.
And so they switch places.
And Amazon starts
to become uttered
in the same breath as
Google, and even now Apple.
So to get back to the
profitability question,
I mean, they just
had inspired a lot
of faith in their
long-term shareholders
and then the analysts that
covered them on Wall Street.
And, for a few years, they
just called their shots
very predictably.
And then, about a year ago,
they started to telegraph
that they were going into
another investment phase,
and building fulfillment
centers all over the country.
They're building one
right down the 580,
and getting into new kinds of
hardware, like the Kindle Fire
tablets, and expanding
internationally,
and expanding
Amazon Web Services.
And so they're losing money.
But they've projected that
they would lose money.
And so nobody's surprised by it.
And they're so happy to
see that Amazon's grown
so quickly-- much faster
than the rest of e-commerce--
and extremely faster
than retail, which
means they're taking customers
away from their competitors,
and locking people up.
And those customers
are doing a lot
of their shopping on Amazon.
And that's why we see the
optimism, particularly
on days like today.
PRESENTER: You
start the prologue
of the book talking
about how Amazon loves
to delight its customers
when something arrives early.
And that actually happened
to me last night, which was--
BRAD STONE: OK, now you have
to tell us what you got.
PRESENTER: It was
just a hard drive.
I just needed-- I think
my computer hard drive was
failing, so I just
needed to back it up,
and I was getting worried.
And it was supposed
to arrive today.
It arrived last night.
Now all my data's
safe and sound.
I'm pretty happy.
Shifting gears a little bit,
because the book is-- just
like in real life, it's
just as much Amazon
as it is Jeff Bezos.
And the book is in the same way.
And you open the book
talking about this childhood,
his education, and so on.
I was just left wondering,
during his years
at D. E. Shaw, when
he first had the idea
to start Amazon, when
he saw this tsunami that
was the internet coming-- you
wisely, I think, in the book,
never said whether you
thought he saw something
that nobody else did,
or if he was just
at the right place
at the right time.
How much was this circumstance?
And how much was it him?
And these are
intertwined, but I just
wanted to ask you
your thoughts--
BRAD STONE: Absolutely--
PRESENTER: --and your
opinions on that.
BRAD STONE: Good question.
I think it was both.
The reason that chapter one--
So the prologue of the book
starts with an
account of his-- he's
in sixth grade at a school.
And there was
actually a woman that
wrote a book about that school.
And he's referred to with
a pseudonym named Tim.
And so it's just this
incredible account
of this visionary
figure as a 12th-grader.
But chapter one is D. E. Shaw.
And the reason I
started there is
because it is an
extraordinary hedge fund.
It is one of the first
quantitative hedge funds,
so using computers
and algorithms
to trade stocks and bonds.
But David Shaw, who's a
former computer science
professor at Columbia,
sees the internet
coming far sooner than anyone.
And he also has a very different
vision of D. E. Shaw, not as
a hedge fund, but as
a technology company,
whose first business is
financial instruments.
And it's because he has
that vision that he's
hiring not just Wall
Street guys like Bezos,
who had been at Bankers Trust
and a few other Wall Street
institutions, but
lots of generalists.
In fact, Jeff's wife
worked at D. E. Shaw,
and she was an English major.
And he really had this vision
that they would expand.
And so, in 1993, they've
got these very early reports
about how the
internet is expanding,
and how web protocol
is jumping up,
vis-a-vis other internet
tools of the time.
And he starts
meeting with Bezos.
Shaw and Bezos
were meeting weekly
to talk-- to brainstorm-- the
next business for D. E. Shaw.
And they're brainstorming
a lot of internet ideas.
And one of the ideas
discussed at the time
is Juno, which is one of the
first free email services,
and a predecessor to Gmail.
And Farsight Financial Services
comes out of D. E. Shaw.
That's kind of an
E*TRADE of the mid-'90s.
It was acquired, I
think, by Merrill Lynch.
And then they are roughly
speaking about this idea
called "the everything
store," which
is actually why I
titled the book that.
And it's this just vague
notion that maybe the internet
can be an intermediary to
sell any kind of product.
And I don't think they
went any further than that.
But Jeff then went off on his
own, and decided, you know,
you probably can't do
anything right away.
But you should focus on one
thing, and be great at that.
And, as we discussed
before, he selected books.
So I think it was,
in large part,
the culture there
and the environment.
And he's gone and tried to
recreate something similar
at Amazon.
But it was also, obviously--
without him, there's
no company.
Because it's then his
relentless and focus,
and complete
unwillingness to blink
in moments of the
company's history,
when all his senior execs--
almost all of them-- leave.
And the world thinks
that he's an idiot.
And the company's
stock is in the tank.
All these idea stories
end up being complicated.
But the success of the
company, in large part,
can be easily credited to
his drive and intellect.
PRESENTER: To me personally,
one of the most interesting
little details
about the book-- I'm
not sure how many of--
everyone here is aware of,
but Jeff personally invested
in Google back in 1998
around Series A, right?
Right before or--
BRAD STONE: That's right.
PRESENTER: --right after it.
And is this, do you think-- So
continuing with that question,
did he just have the foresight
that few other people did?
And he saw this
great opportunity,
and he invested into it?
Or was it just more
it was coming anyways,
and he just happened
to be there?
BRAD STONE: I think
it was fortuitous.
He had acquired a
company called Junglee.
It was like the first
comparative shopping engine.
And the COO of Junglee
was Ram Shriram,
one of your board members.
And he, on a trip
to the Bay Area,
introduced Jeff to
Larry and Sergey.
I think it was at Ram's house.
It was on a weekend.
And he was-- actually
Round A had closed.
But Jeff was so impressed by
Larry and Sergey's-- what he
described as their stubbornness
about not putting ads
on the main page, that he
was immediately intrigued.
And also, it's what
he's always done,
which is bet on the internet.
I mean, that's
simplifying things,
but he's the guy that bet
the biggest on the internet.
He pushed the most
chips on the table.
He raised the most money
of any internet company--
I mean, over $2 billion in debt.
It almost sank the company.
I mean, he was
just-- and he talks
about long-term
orientation, and optimism.
But you can kind of
reduce it to balls, right?
He just bet.
And with the Google
prototype, he probably
saw this is a better
way to search.
And the way Ram describes
it, is the Round was closed.
And Jeff said, I want in.
I didn't get too deep into
the mechanics of that,
but Ram's working for
Jeff at the time, and now
subsequently, and
reflecting on it,
is amazed at how Jeff kind of
knew just how far to push it.
And in fact, the
Round was reopened.
And Jeff was able to invest.
And he won't say,
and likely nobody
knows, if he owns
any Google stock.
I would imagine that he
probably sold it after the IPO.
But it's one of those
quirks of history.
And I think it's interesting
that you bring it up,
because I think it's
insightful about his character.
PRESENTER: It's
fairly well known
that Amazon doesn't
necessarily provide
too many perks to
their employees.
Employees have to
pay for parking.
They have to pay
for a lot of things,
compared to Google, which is
on the other end of spectrum
to that, where, because of our
philosophy around all of that,
employees have a lot that
is provided for them.
And obviously each one
of these strategies
works well for the company.
But from your perspective,
having covered these companies
for so many years,
how do you see these?
How do you understand these
two wildly different--
BRAD STONE: Yeah,
that lavish cafeteria
that you guys have over there?
That does not exist at
Amazon's offices in Seattle.
They have a cafeteria, but you
have to pay for everything.
So very early on, Jeff read
Sam Walton's autobiography.
And he, right away,
understood what
it takes to be a
discount retailer.
Discount retailers-- which is
essentially what Amazon is.
I mean, it has these
other businesses,
but they want to sell you a
product at the lowest price.
And discount retailers are
built on low cost structures.
You save pennies
in your operations
so you can charge less
than your competitor.
And that's why scale matters.
And that's why
other retailers are
tend to have those same
values of frugality.
Jeff just extracted that
DNA outside of Walmart
and implanted it in Amazon.
And so it is very frugal.
They've taken it almost
to comical extremes.
The prototypical example
are the door desks,
where they just spend the
minimum amount of money
to build a desk kit.
And employees often assemble
their desks on their first day.
And salaries aren't
above industry average.
When they take a job
candidate out to lunch,
they can't expense that.
When I would dine with
Amazon executives,
they would all-- in researching
the book-- they would all,
very theatrically, make
a point of tearing up
the receipt
afterwards, and saying,
the company isn't
paying for this.
I am.
And they're actually,
in some ways,
modeling Jeff's own behavior.
Because he does that.
And it's tempting
to kind of think
of it as some kind of
character flaw of the company,
or a disadvantage, but it's a
value that they're proud of.
It's posted on the website
in their corporate values.
And it's because it
translates, in their business,
directly into the lower prices
and their customer focus.
So without it, they
wouldn't be able to compete
as they do with the Walmarts
and the Targets of the world.
PRESENTER: In your odyssey
in writing the book,
you went to search for
Jeff's biological father.
And do you just want
to share whatever
you're comfortable
with about this?
BRAD STONE: Oh,
yeah, absolutely.
I, in telling the
Amazon story, of course,
I need to tell the
story of Jeff Bezos.
And in reflecting on what
was known of his story,
it jumped out at me that, like
so many other iconic business
leaders, political
leaders, cultural leaders,
there are some sort of
interesting dynamics
to his early childhood, like
Steve Jobs, or Barack Obama,
or Bill Clinton.
It's sort of
inexplicable, but he never
knew his biological father.
His parents had him when
they were teenagers.
And they were married,
but his biological father
left his wife when he was three.
And he's admitted this.
It was never a secret.
And the name was known.
And I thought that this
is sort of a missing
piece about the Amazon story.
Who was this guy?
And did he-- in some way,
did the circumstances
of his childhood
lead him to be such
a unique and relentless figure?
He's an unusual person.
So where does that come from?
So long story short, I decided
to try to find this guy.
And the first thing I did
was, I was searching newspaper
archives in the
1960s in Albuquerque,
New Mexico, which is
where he was born.
And I found, to my
utter astonishment,
that this guy was part
of a unicycle troupe
that traveled the country.
And they were in
circuses, which,
if you remember the years
when Jeff was inseparable
with his Segway, was a
really bizarre coincidence.
Like, was there some sort
of genetic predisposition
to wheeled vehicles?
I didn't know.
So I found him running a bike
store outside of Phoenix.
And I went to visit him.
And it turned out,
to my surprise,
that he hadn't known
what happened to his son.
He lost track of the family.
Jeff's mom remarried.
And they changed
their name to Bezos.
And he had lost track, and
had spent his whole life
wondering what
happened to the kid
that he had when he
was 18 years old.
And it was a remarkable story.
It was extremely unexpected.
And it is what it is.
I never really was able
to draw any conclusions
about whether that really
had an impact on the leader
that he became.
But I think if you're
someone like Jeff Bezos,
you've changed the
world in numerous ways.
You've changed the way the world
shops, and the way the world
reads, and increasingly
the way startups are run.
It's like people want to
know where you came from.
And in a way, I felt like this
was a necessary story to tell.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
curious to know.
You've covered Jeff all
throughout his life,
or about every
period of his life.
We hear stories
about Bill Gates,
and how he was the
first one in high school
to have a computer club.
And that's how he
triggered his passion
for technology, and Steve Jobs,
and his search for perfection.
What is it that drives Jeff
to be the character that he
is today-- very frugal,
very driven, very focused.
Mentioned in a similar vein
as the biological father.
But what--
BRAD STONE: What
ultimately drives him?
AUDIENCE: And maybe what
historical event or what
[INAUDIBLE]
BRAD STONE: Well, I think
there are a number of things.
I'll pick out a couple.
One is he was a huge
fan of "Star Trek," paid
a lot of attention to the
Apollo moon missions growing up,
and developed an extreme
passion for space.
And in fact, when
he was valedictorian
of his high school
in Miami, his speech
was about creating
human colonies in space.
And some of his friends
from high school
said that he always
wanted to be wealthy.
He was always very driven.
And the end goal
was always is to be
able to finance some kind of
space exploration, which sounds
wacky, but he's
actually doing it.
He's got another company
called Blue Origin, based
in the Seattle area, and
they're building rockets.
Another technological
kind of inspiration
is-- so in the
prologue, when I'm
describing this old account
of his life in middle school,
he's a sixth grader, they have--
very much like Bill Gates.
They've got a computer, like
a teletype computer, donated
by a local company.
And he is leading the
group of sixth graders
in playing with this
computer, like clearly,
for so many of that generation,
a very formative experience.
But in terms of what
drives him today--
I think what he would say
is building an enduring
company, an enduring
customer-focused company.
And maybe what his
critics would say
is it's being the last man
standing, and the smartest
guy in the room, and
out-witting rivals.
And look, he's
competitive, also,
so I think it's a combination
of those two things.
AUDIENCE: If someone
walked up to you,
and wasn't familiar with the
company, and they said, hey,
Brad.
Amazon-- what do they do?
What is your response to that?
BRAD STONE: Amazon is in the
business of value of selling
everything, from physical
goods-- all the way from books,
to furniture, lawn chairs,
and huge two-ton safes--
to digital products, from
digital music, and eBooks,
to streaming video, to
things that we don't even
think of as products to be
sold-- enterprise services,
storage and compute cycles.
So it's really, in
some ways, like this
the extreme distributor
on steroids, or retailer
that's in the business
of selling its customers
everything and
anything, and doing so
at extremely
competitive low prices.
And using the momentum
of its business,
and all the cash
that it generates,
to just relentlessly expand.
I think that's another
key point that I
would try to get into
that explanation.
This is a company
on the move, that it
is going blob-like in almost
every conceivable direction.
It's pretty amazing--
international expansion,
product categories.
They just started selling art.
They're selling apparel.
The devices-- obviously, as you
guys know, not just the Kindle
and Kindle Fire tablets, but
maybe soon the set-top box,
maybe soon a phone-- all, of
course, with the help of Google
and it's open-source
Android operating system.
So a restless
company, and one that,
even though it might
take on new forms,
will still ultimately be in
the business of selling things.
AUDIENCE: How do you compare him
to other past American business
leaders, like Henry
Ford and others?
What are some of the
similar-- I'm not sure
if you've looked
at similarities.
And obviously the
world is different,
so you have to kind of-- but
what things are similar today?
And what are very different?
BRAD STONE: I think the
points of comparison
that I would be most qualified
to make-- because I haven't
done a lot of
historical research,
but I've covered
technology for 15 years.
He's just cut from
the same cloth,
I think, as Steve Jobs,
Bill Gates, Andy Grove,
maybe occasionally
Larry and Sergey,
in having not just this
relentless drive, but extremely
high standards, occasional
impatience with the people
around them who are not
meeting their high standards,
and creative ways of
expressing that impatience.
And a willingness
to just think big.
And that's obviously what's
happening here at Google.
And although I would
say it's interesting,
Amazon's moon shots
are sort of all
in the purview of kind of Jeff's
own independent activities--
and so, of course, Blue Origin,
and the Clock of the Long Now.
And he recently went and bought
the Washington Post company--
so very much like that small
handful of technology leaders,
in a lot of similarities.
It can be uncomfortable to
work with him, to work for him.
But it's probably why
Amazon is so successful.
Because he's never allowed
anyone to rest on their laurels
or to treat Amazon
like a country club.
You don't coast at Amazon.
They're working
pretty hard up there.
AUDIENCE: So you've used the
word relentless many times.
And I've heard that
word used before.
But you also used a
phrase that really
caught my attention,
which is a refusal
to blink in the face of
naysayers, basically.
Have you found any point at
which that began to emerge?
Was that when he
was a sixth-grader?
Or was it earlier or later?
It's a very admirable
trait to me.
BRAD STONE: I think it really
took a while to emerge.
I think, in the very
early years of Amazon,
he was much more receptive
to input from the outside,
a lot less sure on his feet.
In fact, in 1999,
he sort of allows
his board to appoint a COO.
It's this one ten-month
experiment in Amazon's history
that does not work out.
And I tell that story
in the book, too.
And maybe as a result of that
experience, and the result
of this moment-- when the world
does not believe in Amazon,
and a lot of his
senior teams leave--
he refuses to give any ground.
And he says we're
still on this mission.
And he still is thinking
aggressively about expansion.
In the midst of the
decline, the crash
in Amazon stock, the second
or third Harry Potter book
comes out.
And he-- which is
sort of interesting.
In a weird way, Harry Potter
might have saved Amazon.
It was very fortuitous.
Because there was such
unusual demand for that book.
But Amazon's
finances are a mess.
They're driving
towards profitability.
And he basically
says we're going
to deliver this book on the
Saturday that it comes out.
And we're not going
to charge any--
we're going to give everyone
free two-day shipping.
And we're not going to
charge extra for it.
And his CFO at the time,
Warren Jenson, who I spoke to,
doesn't admit to
losing hair over that.
But he's bald.
So I'll just say that.
But it's crazy.
It's crazy.
But he is extremely
customer-focused-- realizes
that it'll engender
a lot a loyalty
and some kind of
magical experiences
for the Harry Potter fans.
And that it's-- even
more kind of strategic--
that it's incredible
branding opportunity.
And the thing I did is, as
I was writing about that,
is I used LexisNexis to go find
out how many clips Amazon got,
how many media mentions.
And it was like hundreds.
Maybe it was thousands.
I can't remember
what the number is.
And in fact, his
colleagues at the time--
there is a quote in the
book along the lines of,
he has ice water running
through his veins.
And maybe I'm sounding
overly sycophantic right now.
And there are plenty
of reasons to criticize
Amazon, particularly for its
behavior toward smaller rivals
and sometimes partners.
But it's an incredible moment
in Amazon's history, where
he just stands his
ground, and says,
we're going to delight
our customers right now.
And we'll make the
finances work later.
And he did.
AUDIENCE: So you've
said a few times
how he's very relentless,
but also very focused,
and doesn't really have fear
in his eyes or anything.
But I did want to ask
you, if you look ahead
towards the future a little
bit, where would Jeff be afraid?
Who would he be afraid of?
Because in the retail space,
there's a giant like Walmart.
In the internet space,
there's a giant like Google.
In the device space,
there's a giant like Apple.
Or is it the thing that is yet
to come that he's afraid of?
So what would Jeff be
worried about or afraid of?
Even though he has ice in
his veins, like you say,
he's still human.
So what do you
think it would be?
And why?
Why would he be afraid of that?
BRAD STONE: Well, of course I
can't-- and I wouldn't presume
to-- speak for him.
And I know what he would
say, if we asked him
that, which is that he would say
that Amazon is customer-focused
and not competitor-focused.
So they pay attention
to what customers do,
but it's not where they
put their attention.
And frankly, I'm not sure
I completely buy that.
Because there are plenty
of examples in Amazon's
history where they
clearly fear an upstart.
And the Zappos story,
which I told in the book
is a great example.
And the diapers.com story
is another good example,
where these e-commerce companies
achieve breakaway velocity.
In the case of Zappos,
with a very flexible brand
and a great customer experience.
So in those cases, I think they
started to really pay attention
to companies that were kind
that out-Amazoning Amazon
in other product categories--
in shoes for Zappos,
in diapers and other household
goods where Amazon wasn't
so strong at the time.
So I think the general
point is he's probably
most scared of other
business operators who
think like he does, who
want to inspire loyalty,
and are kind of, in some ways,
willing to spend recklessly.
Zappos was a
billion-dollar company,
but it wasn't all
that profitable.
Because customers were
buying 10 pairs of shoes
and sending back nine.
Tony Hsieh was as
nuts as Jeff is.
And then, more recently,
I think-- clearly they
are very-- I'm not
going to say worried.
But Apple and Google loom
very large on their radar.
And we're seeing a lot
of that manifest itself
in the new Kindle Fire
tablets and their strategy
with Android.
I have a quote in the book
that Tim O'Reilly relayed
to me, which is
Jeff saying to him,
we don't have many
big advantages.
So we have to weave together
a rope of smaller advantages.
And he was saying
that in the context
of the one-click
patent, and why Amazon
was asserting this patent--
even though I think
Jeff will probably readily
agree that the patent
system is broken.
But I think that's
what he's doing today
with all of Amazon's digital
services and hardware,
where you see them take IMDB,
this asset that they've owned
for so long, and draw some of
the metadata about TV shows
and movies into the
Kindle Fire tablet.
And you just see
him-- and Prime is
kind of the linchpin of
this strategy-- of bringing
in elements from all corners of
the organization-- advertising
is another one-- to kind
of subsidize these devices,
lower their price, make them
more appealing competitors
to the Nexus tablets
or the iPads.
And I think he clearly
realizes that a big large part
of this battle,
particularly around media,
is going to be fought and
won between Apple, Google,
Amazon, or perhaps other members
of the Android ecosystem.
So I would say that's
probably the biggest
competitive challenge
to Amazon right now.
AUDIENCE: So how do you think
this book has been received
at Amazon by the folks you
spoke to and by folks maybe you
didn't?
And were there any
issues that came up
as you were compiling
drafts of this,
if you can speak about them?
BRAD STONE: Sure.
I don't have a lot of insight
into how it's been received.
And I didn't expect a lot of
feedback, at least right away.
I think it's, as I said
at the very beginning,
it's a company that doesn't
invite this kind of scrutiny.
And I think they
participated, to an extent,
to ensure that their
viewpoint was known.
But the first thing you're
going to hear from any Amazon
spokesperson is "no comment."
And sometimes it's almost a
joke among the press corps.
And because, again, they're
primarily in retail.
And it's an area
where margins are low.
And insight is your
competitive weapon.
And you can be copied
quickly by rivals.
So they genetically
keep to themselves.
And I've heard some stuff.
I've heard from some Amazon
folks, current and former,
that said, you got
the story right.
And to be honest,
I've heard some folks
who felt like there were
corners of the account that
were overly tough.
And, from my perspective, that's
kind of what you want to hear.
Of course I'm curious to
know what, ultimately, Jeff
thought of it.
And I'm not sure
I'll ever find out
AUDIENCE: So you spoke to, I
guess, a few people at Amazon,
and you have been researching.
So how much do you think
Amazon is Bezos-dependent?
And if, let's say, he were
to focus on another venture,
and appoint someone
else in his place,
how do you think Amazon would
change or not change at all?
How much of his
philosophy has he
ingrained in people there now?
BRAD STONE: Very good question.
I think, particularly if
you're an Amazon shareholder,
that's probably
your biggest worry.
And it's not a short-term worry.
But Jeff's about to
turn 50 in January.
But it's a long-term worry.
The company is
now so diversified
that I'm not sure there's
anyone as versatile
as he is to run it.
But to your second
point, there are
executives at Amazon that
have been by his side
for many years, that think like
he does, that exhibit a lot
of his mannerisms, that are
very familiar with the business.
And that's Jeff Wilke, who runs
the North American consumer
businesses; and Andy
Jassy; who runs Amazon Web
Services; and Diego Piacentini,
who came from Apple,
and runs the international
businesses at Amazon.
I mean even though there
is a lot of turnover
in the lower and
middle ranks of Amazon,
the upper ranks have
remained relatively stable
since the period I referred
to during the dot-com bust,
when there was major churn.
But Jeff's a
singular individual.
And in a lot of
ways, the company
is tailored to how he thinks.
So you guys probably know that
meetings are started at Amazon
by reading six-page
documents called narratives.
And that's because
that is how he
prefers to digest information.
He's kind of trained everyone
around him, the entire company,
to do that as well.
But it really is
tailored toward him.
And I describe it,
in the last chapter
of the book, the company as
a series of chess boards,
all perfectly
aligned, so that he
can play as many games
as possible at once.
So when you lose
your chess master,
your grandmaster
has to be replaced.
And as we've seen at
Apple, another company that
was kind of tailored towards one
individual and how he thinks,
the transition is never easy.
AUDIENCE: The question
around the future
you mentioned, after
a couple decades,
Jeff said it's too
early to tell the story.
Is there any way you can
project out in the future
and paint a picture about what
that second half of the story
might look like?
Where they're going?
What his biggest Moonshot
ambitions are, for example?
BRAD STONE: Well,
first all, I'll
say that I don't
think it is too early.
I just think that's what he says
to kind of keep authors at bay.
It's a convenient sort
of trope, and sort
of like a stiff arm
to anybody that's
trying to get too
close to the company.
But what does the future hold?
I mean, I think the
goal is Walmart scale,
in terms of the retail business.
So, actually, I'm
not even sure what
Walmart's revenues
were last year.
But let's say it's $300
billion, and Amazon's on track
to make $75 billion this year.
So they still have
a long way to go.
There's a lot of
international markets
where Amazon has
very little presence.
And in some regions
of the world,
it's because the shipping
infrastructure is immature.
And credit card
processing is immature.
And the Amazon model
doesn't scale there.
And then there are other
parts of the world,
I think Mexico and
India, and maybe Brazil,
where they've chosen to use
the Kindle business as a Trojan
horse, and start their eBook--
and maybe, in some cases,
their digital
businesses-- there.
So they're expanding.
So I think, at one point,
the answer to your question
is Amazon is a global business
with a Walmart-like footprint.
And as to other parts
of the business,
like digital, I
just think there's
no limit to the ambition.
So it'll be phones.
It'll be tablets.
It'll be set-top boxes.
It might be Amazon
Glass, at some point.
They'll probably call
it something else.
But when you think
about it, for Jeff,
customers walking into a
store with their glasses,
and seeing the Amazon price
on every product-- that's
pretty scary, now
that I think about it.
But he's expansive
in his vision,
and loves the technology.
And so I'm sure he sees
a lot of opportunity
probably almost everywhere, but
particularly in the hardware
business and in Amazon's Lab126
operations here in Silicon
Valley.
PRESENTER: Awesome.
Thank you, guys.